good morning believe nation today's
message is don't lose sight of what
matters over to you Lindsey Stirling
awake in espresso TV gold I wish so when
I first started I wish I had realized
that people were the most important
thing to me because there was a time you
know I I'm such a hard worker and when
your passion is what you do for a living
it's very hard to not become a
workaholic and there was a time when I
just almost lost sight of everything
that was most important to me because I
was working so hard and I was pushing so
hard for these these dreams and these
goals and everything I wanted in life
and my life started to look very grey
and colorless and I just I realized I
had lost a lot of depth because I wasn't
making time for those most important
things which are my family and you know
the people in my life or someone that
may be needed me at a time but I was too
busy to even notice and those are the
things that you can't you can't fulfill
your full passion whether it's through
music or art or dance if you've lost
sight of the things that make you a real
person and I had to like refined myself
almost like wow what is it that makes me
me and once I refound that it's like
everything else came together again I
was able to write again I was able to
create but without those things then you
lose sight of everything my quick take
on this is people are always striving to
be balanced right you won't have a
balanced life you gotta balance your
work you got to balance your life you
get bounced all the things that you need
to have in your life and the thing is as
soon as you set your schedule your ideal
schedule you have to realize that
balance is only for a certain moment in
time and that your life will change your
needs will change your circumstances
will change and so your life has to
change to accommodate it right how much
time you spend on your business you may
be able to spend a ton of time now
because you don't have kids and you're
not marrying over the equipment's and
maybe you if you spent that much time
when you are older that would be a
problem for you because
want to spend more time in other places
you need to have a constant self audit
on your schedule for me I usually look
at it every quarter every couple of
months I'll be looking at it saying hmm
where does my life feel a little bit out
of balance taking over Toronto dance
salsa my life started to get out of
balance there's too much work I didn't
have a spot in my schedule to fit it in
so I had to clear up Monday so I can
focus on tds stuff on mondays and some
of the evenings to meet with the
instructors and talk about their growth
and then my life came back into balance
and when new opportunities come your way
or something happens in your personal
life or in your business that forces you
to go in a different direction you need
to do another self audit to think about
okay how do I make this fit and schedule
in the personal stuff too because too
often you only scheduled in the business
stuff and then that bleeds into your
personal life and that has an impact on
all the relationships with your parents
with your wife or husband with your kids
your friends all the important people in
your life and so I would encourage you
to do a constant self audit at least
once a quarter look at how are you
spending your time doesn't make sense
does something feel out of whack are you
stressed out that you're not getting
things done are you stressed out you're
not spend enough time with that person
and when you feel that way adjust your
schedule so you are in balance again
there is no one perfect schedule for
anybody there's only the perfect
schedule for you today and anytime
something again feels out of whack you
got to make some adjustments so the
question they today is I'm curious what
do you do to stay balanced and make sure
you're spending time on the right things
leave any comments below I'm going to
join the discussion thank you so much
for watching have an amazing day need to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events better
I spray so give me go